oh look at the baby monkey
this is the thing look at this little
guy i'm sorry ian celebus monkey or
he just recognized me and freaked out i
know these things evolved from humans
actually
oh look at this look at that cute little
bottle you've got there there's a bottle
you could try to feed him
yeah i don't think you're gonna have to
work very hard at it
oh look it's like he got that on an
airline isn't it
oh that is so sweet and so it's what
kind of uh monkey it's called a tonkian
celebus monkey they come from indonesia
and this is a six-month-old baby
they normally don't wear diapers but
yeah oh really they are
suit they're not they're not born in
diapers are they
fascinating so cute and uh how old is
this
little baby hey where are you going
there buddy he's six months old yeah
okay
and when he's fully grown he'll be
possibly 24 to
30 inches um and these animals live in
troops
that's so nice oh oh
the males together and the females stay
together
when when the the males recognize that
the females are in heat they'll stay
around them for about 10 days
right before they does he know now that
i'm in heat is any sense
that i'm ready to get it on with any
monkey hey hey okay he does
he does he didn't like that at all he
was like
i'm not into that all right well thank
you he's a do you have a name
uh yes he does it's sam sam okay all
right very nice well
are you nice to meet you sam sam's a
little sweetie now sam's trying to
escape from you
see uh we'll put him over here and never
met that guy
he's even worked for you random people
are coming out of the audience to take
the animals away
here's another baby and this is a baby
wallaby called
bennett's wallaby and they come from uh
australia tasmania
would this drink out of the same bottle
he might yes and uh should they share
should they share inter-species germs or
is that okay
he said he just smelled monkey on him
he's like uh no no that's
what we can do here what what's this
right here he might take the berry i
don't know
okay wow this i've never seen oh well
these are actually grazers but
in captivity they'll they'll certainly
take fruits what do you see that's the
finickiest eater i've ever seen
well he's a little yeah this is like a
little i don't think so not for me
thank you very much i appreciate it but
i don't think so no
just sniffing it and not really doing
anything how does this animal survive in
the wild
actually they are incredible survivors
because they live in very dry areas and
right and they they graze and oftentimes
don't have standing water available to
drink
smell the product in my hair
clyde if i ever get the chance i'll kill
you um
all right well we should move along uh
oh now now once i'm not touching it he
wants the berry okay come with me uh
sweetie right there all right oh hi how
are you
nice to see you all right thank you oh
my god here we go now we're talking
here's here's an amazing animal that
comes from the rainforest this looks
like something
i have to be honest this looks like
something from outer space
i'm not kidding look at those claws and
that what is this animal
this is a two-toed sloth it should
actually be called a two-toed
toenail sloth actually but um this
animal hangs upside down in a cycopraya
tree
so these these things are found in the
wild these are
little mini jungle gyms i brought this
back from my last amazon show yeah
that's great these grow naturally in the
wild will you eat this strawberry
yes i think he might take a grape if he
doesn't take the strawberry okay
okay it doesn't really i can't believe
these animals are all like supermodels
they're like
you want to grape their sloth do you
like oh there we go oh
that's very look at those eyes those are
the eyes of a killer
and this is an animal that just likes to
kind of hang out and chill they they eat
very little they have slow metabolisms
once a week they come an uncle like that
[Applause]
so this guy doesn't do that much just
sort of hangs there and eats grapes all
day
as i started to say he'll come down oh i
guess you think i talk too much huh
i'm sorry clyde he'll defecate at the
the base of the tree
oh great yeah i'm glad you interrupted
what i was saying
conan i gotta get this in what is it
clyde it is suffocate
it's important stuff it's not important
stuff
it is because he fertilizes the tree
that he he lives off of
and he takes a chance on getting preyed
upon by a jaguar or something while he's
doing this so this animal risks death to
uh feed the trees
exactly right that's a dumb animal uh
all right can we we should head over
head over this way i want to see what
this is all about right here
this is where clyde likes to bathe every
evening
what is this this is oh my god this is a
is this a shark
this is a shark this is a nurse shark
and they live in the
coastal waters
ah is it okay to look at this thing and
are those it's uh
teeth or is that a mustache they have
thousands of serrated teeth
which they used to crush uh a shellfish
and he could
he could do a good job at your hand i
mean they're not why didn't you tell me
that
before the segment why shove the shark
into my suit jacket and then tell me
that it's a killer they're not normally
aggressive but
uh they certainly can is it okay out of
the water it's actually
for a brief period of time actually uh
they can stay out of water much longer
than one would think
okay and what he's doing here he's using
muscles behind his gills
yes and if he were in the water he'd
pump the water through his
his mouth and and out past the gills
so that he can stay at the bottom yes
and and
continue to extract oxygen from the
water without uh without moving like
most sharks
that was a long story hey
hey hey take it easy what are you doing
why make him pay for your bad anecdote
all right we got one we got time for one
more okay one more
where where's the last python where's
that
[Music]
oh my god you take the head conan
take the head oh thanks great that's the
part that chop chop
i'll tell you why how long is this
python first of all snake is about 17
and a half feet weighs 180 pounds
and if you notice his eyes are opaque
yeah he's getting ready to shed his skin
during this time
okay he's moving he's moving in a weird
way a little more nasty when they're
ready is he getting mad right now why is
he contracting like this
what's happening he's pulling his head
back and he's looking at me in this
weird way
can he bite can this animal bite ken he
has about a hundred needle sharp teeth
which kind of curved back
you're an ass what are you talking about
what are you talking about
are you choking my snake no i'm not
choking your snake
he's coming up this way he's coming up
this way get behind
pretty ladies oh he's coming back
all right is there any way that i can
summon the shark to my defense like
aquaman
right shark untie attack snake
baby monkey look at the sloth could care
less about what's happening
on this tv show now whatever the python
would be very happy to uh
all right we're gonna take a break
because we're gonna have to go but thank
you for bringing these animals here
clyde peeling everyone simon cowell
you